crecen los llamados de advertencia por
la salud del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni actualmente en prisión esta fue
la petición de su hija daiana baldaia en
twitter permitan que un médico visite a
mi padre navalny está en huelga de
hambre desde el 31 de marzo en protesta
por no poder ser atendido por su médico
personal fuera de la instalación
penitenciaria su estado sería crítico
cerca de un fallo renal y cardíaco
la advertencia vino de la familia del
entorno político y de sus médicos a los
que se les negó el acceso a la prisión
edward pasamos aquí dos horas todos
saben que alexéi navalni está muy grave
por desgracia no se nos permitió verlo
nada ni denuncia que le están amenazando
con ponerle una camisa de fuerza para
alimentarle el embajador rusa en reino
unido- aseguró que no van a dejarle
morir en prisión y lo acusó de querer
llamar la atención por supuesto que no
se le permitirá morir en prisión pero
puedo decir que el señor naval ni se
comporta como un hooligan absolutamente
única
el estado de salud de naval ni preocupa
en la comunidad internacional el
ministro de exteriores francés condenó
la situación por la que pasa el líder
opositor ruso comen se tu puso un
oponente político no pues víctima de
envenenamiento químico ha encarcelado a
su regreso ahora alejado de la capital
con graves problemas de salud no es
posible que no ponga dificultad suerte
sino imposible también condenó el trato
naval ni el presidente de eeuu joe biden
totalmente injusto totalmente
inapropiado para haciendo de haber sido
envenenado y luego además la huelga de
hambre hay navalny principal opositor de
vladimir putin fue condenado a dos años
y medio de prisión en febrero por haber
violado la libertad condicional mientras
se recuperaba de un envenenamiento con
no [__] que en alemán ya sus seguidores
en rusia anunciaron protestas
multitudinarias este 21 de abril